[Music]
you should probably mute your video also
till we get started
and when we introduce you we'll put the
videos on again yeah
do you want me to mute my video too yes
all of us stuart will take the first he
will present and then we'll all jump in
at the same time yeah
welcome everyone to the panel discussion
powering
linkedin big data through open source
technologies
uh this panel discussion will be hosted
by simply learn's chief product
officer ananyan and
we will have several speakers from
linkedin but before we start
i do want to run you through the
controls
for webex to participate in the webinar
if you have questions
that you would like the panelists to
address in the q a at the end of the
presentation
please put them in the q a box
address them to all panelists if you
have uh
something that you'd like to put in the
chat window
again address that to all panelists or
to host and presenter
and we will see that
and i'm going to start
with a poll
which
the poll has two questions on it
the first is what
all right let's get the right poll going
what is your current role
and how are you feeling today
you like to ask that last question
because of the
global situation we're all in sometimes
people are anxious
i'd like to check in with everyone
so what is your current job role
or function and how are you feeling
today and we'll leave that open for
about another 20 seconds
and remember to hit submit
closing the poll
in 10 9 8
7.
three two one
and share the poll results
the broad uh distribution of people in
different roles today
fortunately very few of you are in the
thumbs down category
and we hope that this presentation will
help
bill elevate your mood with some good
information from some great people
what i'm gonna do now is turn it over to
anand
who will uh introduce our panel from
linkedin
all right thank you stuart hey welcome
everybody who's uh joined us today
so thrilled to have you here and boy we
have a big crowd we have 171
participants already hopefully growing
further
great to see uh we have a power packed
panel today
and you know i can see why the interest
is there let me introduce the group
that's here
um first of all let me introduce buttons
wasn't rajamani vasanth rajamani is a
director at linkedin where he's
responsible for running
most of linkedin's big data
infrastructure teams collectively the
infrastructure platforms built and
operated by seems power linked its
artificial intelligence
data science and data application his
teams work with popular open source
technologies like hadoop spark and
tensorflow
and prior to linkedin he was a manager
and data our application at linkedin
he did his undergraduate purdue and his
phd from university of texas at austin
both in computer engineering
uh welcome watson it's really great to
have you here yeah pleasure to be here
thanks for having us all right and with
watson we have you know sunita biram
sunita has been at linkedin for more
than 3.5 years as an engineering manager
and leads apache spark team at linkedin
which is responsible for providing
infrastructure that runs more than 80
percent of the offline compute workloads
in linkedin
prior to linkedin seneca worked as the
principal software engineer at yahoo
where she worked on metadata systems
powering yahoo mail
so nico hold the master's degree from
georgia institute of technology welcome
sunita
hi everyone all right and then we have
abhishek kivari abhishek tavari is an
engineering manager at linkedin where he
leads the compute orchestration platform
his team builds and operates azkaban an
open source distributed workflow
management system
which powers various artificial
intelligence data science and
infrastructure workloads
he's an avid open source contributor and
active in the apache goblin community
welcome abhishek
all right and finally we have sumita
chandran sumita chandra is the senior
engineering manager at linkedin where
she leads the data lake group
overseeing stories and security goblin
and delhi she holds a master degree from
arizona state university welcome swimika
all right so let me start this
discussion off with a very simple
question because i noticed that
our audiences from very very you know
background so it's very important for us
to start with something very simple
um you know we're talking about big data
at linkedin today and frankly
i know there are a lot of people who are
confused about big data data engineering
and data science right
how do they relate what is this what do
they really mean
so you know russian submit the team you
know how do we
how do we define big data and how does
that compare to the terms data
engineering data science
can we start with something real simple
and then of course we'd love to hear
what linkedin
does actually this space
yeah so let me get going and this is one
of those questions which is broad enough
that
you know it's probably worth getting a
few different perspectives on so
big data kind of started probably about
10 or 15 years ago
and it's now become a catchphrase that
includes many many different things
and and different people mean different
parts of it so if you're going to look
at different parts of the stack
my teams largely work on providing
infrastructure at scale so the name of
the game here
is how do you build and operate
infrastructure that
cuts across uh you know that can crunch
large-scale data right so what we're
really interested in doing is joining
petabytes of data
so you can answer interesting questions
like like if a company launches a
product and you want to understand
how did that product do with um you know
a small demographic like say middle-aged
people of a certain category or whatever
that kind of slicing and dicing and
understanding how to crunch numbers to
get profiles and things like that so
there's the infrastructure aspects of it
which is
one part um you kind of move a little
bit more
upstream you start building other kinds
of technologies like
you know um you know data processing and
you know
query processing metrics creating
automated systems for creating metrics
doing tracking and things like that so
you can think of those as applications
on top
then you have uh what i would call data
engineers these are people who
essentially build applications um
you know you can think of them as you
know in some senses microservices
sort of things where they're actually
building a few different things
using the um you know using they're
writing spark applications or other
things in there
and then there are data scientists who
are using this
to do interesting analysis um they're
people like
artificial intelligence engineers who
are using the big data to actually do
modeling and stuff like that
so there are there are different talent
profiles across different levels of the
stack and there are different
um um you know
what's right word uh there are different
roles and responsibilities across
what is you know all clubbed under big
data
but it's a large and burgeoning field
now and so it
it encompasses a wide range of things uh
for example
sumita's previous job was running um
you know what we would think of as an a
b testing platform
so sumita do you want to add anything to
it
uh symmetra you are muted you might have
to unmute your store
um yes uh uh i was managing a b testing
platform in the
previous group i was managing um full
stack data engineers and then
back in engineers and front-end
engineers and
uh yeah for the a b testing platform um
it's about you know understanding like
how a feature um
um is uh is it a good feature for the
business
so people usually um try to run an
experiment
as control and treatment and then
understand the metrics before they ship
the feature
so um that's the a b testing
platform we were supporting for the
entire company
and uh yeah so as part of it
uh we were configuring experiments and
then
analyzing experiments on a day-to-day
basis before you conclude an experiment
and shift a feature
um so as part of analyzing experiments
big data plays a key role there
um so data engineers build uh pipelines
for each and
uh every metric and then these metrics
uh get added to
experiments as part of experiment setup
and as a whole
we uh compute metrics and then um
the end users look at the metrics and
then they make a decision
so yeah in some sense i think what i
hear
is you know big data is a big big
overarching sort of blanket
you know topic domain if you make and
then you have sort of architecture
infrastructure folks you have data
engineers who are at the microservices
and applications
and the data scientists product managers
over there at the top for them taking
sort of that data and making it happen
wonderful this is very helpful
now now that we have a definition for
this i guess one question for the
audience and stuart if you can do a poll
what level of expertise do you today
have and this is just an open question
on a scale of one to five
how would you think of yourself in the
data engineering big data space we're
trying to get a sense of how
how many experts we have on this forum
all right you know stewart i think i'll
let you do the countdown again
maybe 30 seconds yeah
we've got about another 20 seconds
and remember to hit submit
we'll pull be closed in about 10 seconds
that's five four three
two one
all right actually this is not very
surprising i think we have a lot of
people who are coming here new
and then there are people who are
interested know a little little bit
but are not experts and then if you have
very small set of people who are
practitioners
and very unsurprisingly not a lot of
seniors are experts which is fine which
is why you're here at the webinar
you want to hear from the experts so
that's great um so i think vasanth
abhishek's
subita i think just to keep in mind
let's uh you know explain it in a way
that
our crowd will understand it because i
think you now know the
level of expertise here as well but that
wasn't i'll hand it over to you i think
you're going to walk us through
linkedin's infrastructure
all right let's go to the next live
stream yep sure
i thought the you know best way to get
started was kind of thinking about
uh how linkedin kind of leverages its
big data infrastructure
and you know the previous question that
ananda asked me a little some of these
things
but it would be kind of useful to kind
of think about how we concretely do it
so if you or you know if you've all been
to linkedin.com or
use linkedin the app you know that there
are lots and lots of these
applications that many of you use for
different purposes for example
you might be interested in knowing you
know which you know there's a there's a
tab or
there's an app widget that will tell you
the jobs you might be interested in
there's another one that tells you the
companies that you should probably
follow because based on your interest in
the fact that you're following um
something about bitcoin you might be
interested in coinbase for instance
right
um there are obvious things like hey
this is someone you might know
because you have connections to somebody
else who knows it or
somebody else who knows this person um
you know you you have trend analysis
like hey i know that you're interested
in this topic because you browse these
things before you know you show a lot of
interest in
maybe software architectures and you
know there'll be topics that pop up that
say hey
uh are you interested in this topic
right
and all of this at some level is what we
would call a data application
right because uh there's nothing about
this application that is generic right
uh
anand and me could be twin brothers
growing up in the same household but we
would have a very different
profile view or application experience
with each of these
because our interests are going to be
very different right we
are going to browse different things we
are going to be connected to different
kinds of people
um et cetera et cetera right and
the the way we uh um
alan are you saying something yeah by
the way i was going to say thank you for
calling me your twin brother i think
we look very alike and i was you know i
think that makes sense
so uh fundamentally all of this is
powered because we kind of
understand what people are doing on the
site by looking at the data that they
generate
right so when you go to the site you
drop a bunch of crumbs saying hey
you clicked on this person's profile or
you um
you know we're following this topic and
all of this gives
us the ability to add a ton of value
and all of that value is kind of powered
by the big data stack
right um and so that's one way in which
our engagement with our users
kind of goes up significantly because
we're able to power all of this by
crunching a large amount of data and
personalizing a lot of stuff for you
uh by the way this is pretty attractive
so you know feel free to i don't know
what the mechanism for
um yeah i think but what i'll do is i'll
be monitoring the question answer
section anyway so
you know you can go through the program
as questions come up i will
present them at the right time so don't
worry about that all right perfect
uh next slide then
let's do it next slide please yeah um
another kind of example
is how do we actually build products
is so in a lot of people think of big
data in the
old sense of the world where it was a
back office activity right
you you you wanted to understand if
you're a
walmart or a you know flipkart or
whatever you want to understand okay
how's my inventory doing you know that's
kind of where all of this analytics
business started
a long time ago but it's evolved
significantly since then right
and the reason it's evolved is because
in most
internet companies and increasingly lots
of other companies
there's a very direct loop between how
products are built
and the big data stack in the previous
slide i gave an example where the loop
comes in from the fact that
you know the the data is being powered
for personalization for the member
experience and the member engagement
but there are other ways in which the
loop sort of feedback loop operates
one is in the way we define metrics so
for example
we might be interested in knowing
understanding
when we launch a feature or a launcher
product what's the engagement level with
this product
right and and and so we might launch a
feature that says
um you know i
we would like to understand or maybe we
would like to define a metric on p y and
k
that says p9 case people you may know
right um in the previous slide i showed
an example of that
we'd like to understand how it's doing
and one of the things that we'll do is
we'll define a metric that says
a high quality engagement is uh you know
we the way we define it is we want high
quality connections which are both
invitation sent and invitations accepted
um and so then we what we would do is if
you define this as a precise metric
um as the activity goes on in the site
we would have all these dashboards that
tell us
how is that doing right and this gives
us a very tight feedback loop
on how the product is doing in real time
as it goes through
different phases of adoption
excellent next slide please
um the third example that i wanted to
motivate
uh people with was what sumita had
referred to earlier which is
you know a b testing so take a very
simple
example of how products can be built
better
you have um two sort of examples here
right you have
people you may know on the left hand
side you have
a a non-list view right it's it's
getting
you know people have put people have
been placed as square tiles
and on the right hand side have
essentially a very less view of this
these are the people you may know
right and and and our audiences will
engage differently
you know all these things matter when
you build a product right what is the
user experience going to be like there
are some things that are more appealing
to people than other kinds of layouts
and in um there are many ways to do
something like this you could
have intuition guesses you could have
product but one of the things that we
can do with big data is we can run
control experiments right we can we can
run ramp the product with
uh you know a control of 80 and say hey
we are going to get one
representation of this ui extent that
they empower their customers
um and the real power of big data is
that it allows us to understand what our
customers really need
without having to go and talk to them
for every little detail right and it
allows us to get one step ahead of the
curve
uh i'll pause there and if sunita yeah
i don't know please please do it if you
guys want to add any perspective on just
the top level stuff happy too
just to want to add for a b testing
right so we did an um
analysis uh sometime last year to
understand uh
uh like how how many features we think
as
a
um like by people and
the hypothesis of whatever we were
hoping
would be like by people was 70
of the time wrong right
so if you really go by you know data
decisions i mean that's where you know a
b testing really helps
and um yeah we would uh yeah so
definitely you know when you really do
an experiment um
you will understand uh uh what is really
liked by people and
most of the time we will not be right
make sense so that's why i think it's
key to run an experiment
um before uh shipping in the future
yeah wonderful so i think there are two
questions that i would want to put on
table one i don't want you to answer one
is for future and i would just want to
leave the
audience with a little bit of a view and
we will talk about careers in data
science data engineering data analytics
uh towards the very end so mark i know
you have a question for the panel here
about
you know what does it make what do you
need to do to be actually successful in
this career we'll talk about that i know
sumita you've already answered a little
bit to that question
uh but people talk about careers
separately so you know hold that thought
uh but i have another question for you
right these a b test typically when i
look at the three layer model that we
talked about in terms of
data engineers the architects the
infrastructure and then the data
scientists and product managers right
and av testing sometimes cuts across the
entire stack right so somebody actually
defines the problem statement
somewhere the data pipes get created
someone then makes it all happen right
so getting a little specific right when
a single a b test actually
happens who makes what decisions is that
something that is
you know very linear very standard or is
it very variable
there is a framework um so the framework
uh generally which we
insist uh to the teams inside the
company
is so usually the product managers uh
sit down with uh
data uh you come up with the experiment
hypothesis right and then they define an
experiment they get it reviewed
and then um the engineers and
work to ship the ship and experiment
and then once the experiment gets
shipped uh the data scientists
will look at the results of the
experiment and then um
we'll recommend the decision so that's
the
typical framework but there could be
changes um
uh but yeah this is the standard
framework we insist and
we request folks you know to stick to
the design of the experiment and
not do the p hacking which we call right
because when you
keep looking at the experiment every day
you tend to
bias the experiment right so you need to
stick to the original plan and then you
know be religious about you know
uh following the data
because it's anything to say everyone
data driven but uh
technically most of the times you know
we end up being data informed
so i think it takes really a lot of
courage you know to be
data driven just sticking to the data
and making a decision
it's an actually very interesting point
you make there is what they say that the
data can be made to tell whatever you
wanted to tell right i think you're
making the point of keep it unbiased and
you know don't put your opinions too
strongly on it so it's a very important
point you're making
by the way one thing for the audience i
know there's a huge amount of people
here interested in this
uh i do apologize in advance i will not
be able to answer or bring every single
one of your questions to the panel
if you want to have a strong shot at
actually having the question actually
being asked
kindly make it relevant to the topics
we're covering and i'm happy to bring it
up here for sure right
um so let's let's continue but please
continue
um cool so
from here on i'll give a very high
overview of how
this all works in practice right and and
the goal here isn't to be comprehensive
of what we do
but just to give you a sense of how the
magic happens behind the scenes right
um so if you got to think about a site
like oracle you have
uh i'm sorry a site like linkedin you
have some primary sources of data like
where you kind of put
your what where you went to school your
profile pictures and all of that and
that tends to be
either an oracle database or a scale-out
version like espresso that we built at
linkedin
and then all the data activity that
you're doing
we kind of put it behind a kafka topic
and
so this is these are kind of big
scale-out technologies that capture
a lot of what we need for doing the
you know data crunching and enhancements
that we talked about in the previous
slide
now all of that is useful and and you
know these are systems that are serving
live traffic so you can't really be
doing a ton of data clutching on them
directly
so what we end up doing is we have a
product called goblin and
you know we'll do a few double clicks on
goblin because it's interesting in its
own right
um which kind of mirrors all the
information that's available at linkedin
into what we call our data lake right
and our data lake
is essentially the a large distributed
storage system which is hdfs today
and what we do from there is we create
uh
organized representation of this data uh
why are data sets so
you know data comes in all kinds of
forms and formats and
dali is kind of our internal technology
for doing that right
so from a high level perspective flow
you have
data in disparate places then you kind
of create it in the data lake
and then you organize it in the data
lake right that's that's the point of
the slide
now once you have the data you can
now do interesting things with the data
and you can you know so
there's internal technology like yarn or
mazers that allows us to kind of scale
at
uh thousands of machines or tens of
thousands of machines or whatever is
required to do the latest modeling that
is required right
but there are lots of other technologies
on the computer side like there's
compute engines like spark
presto and they all serve different
purposes for example
spark is extremely well liked by
artificial intelligence engineers
because it allows you to
do more free form programming very much
like you would do in java
or any of the other things that people
have worked with if you don't have
big data experience but some engineering
experience um whereas presto is much
more like a sql database
and it it has a nice property of being
extremely interactive so if you want
something
answered like the example i'd given
earlier which is hey tell me
how something happened with um you know
high school students
in this region of chennai and those are
things that you can easily express as a
sql query and you can get a response in
order of seconds or minutes
depending on how much you're crunching
and you don't have to write a ton of
code for it right
um and then if you're doing the formula
which is i want to write my own program
you need to schedule it and we have a
technology for azkaban on it
and this is kind of the stack with which
we build all the other stuff that we
talked about earlier the reporting stack
the metric stack
the um a b testing stack and all of that
so that's a very whirlwind tool of you
know how it all happens behind the
scenes
i i don't expect all of you to kind of
absorb all these details but my goal was
really just
you know these are interesting things to
check out uh since many of you are
you know basic or nervous and by your
own categorization
i would say if there's interest in the
space although most of these are open
source technology so you should find
plenty of information online
um
i do have one related question you
mentioned that these are open source
technologies uh
and sorry um stewart if you can go back
to this idea so so
look why did obviously you have choices
right you can make an open source stack
or you can go with proprietary stacks to
build this kind of architecture right so
why
why open source what advantage does it
give you and what's the long-term
strategy here
cool so i mean so open source
is there are advantages and you know
like any other technology choice
every company will have to make its own
pragmatic decision
on what technology it brings into the
organization right
um linkedin cares a lot about open
source because
fundamentally you know a lot of the
success we've had is because we've
adopted open source
and been responsible players over there
or we've kind of built technology and
open sourced it and built a community
around it
um the main advantages of doing
something open source
is that you have uh
contributions from people outside the
company
which is often beneficial to the company
right and
often that takes
almo so to give you an example
when we were scaling hdfs uh you know
there are very few companies that use
hdfs at our scale
and so you know most of the innovation
of making it happen
will be required by no more than two or
three companies
on earth but the advantage was that
those two or three companies were all
inclined to solving the same problem and
so we all collaborated in solving that
problem
right um and and what that means is that
we often get the best of breed uh
engineering talent and engineering ideas
not just from one place but from
multiple places
um now there's a downside risk which is
you know like anything else
the wider the coordination and less the
control you have the harder it is to
manage
but um but that's a pragmatic choice
that every company has to make and at
linkedin we've
benefited greatly from our commitment to
open source
uh we've gotten a lot out of it uh both
from a recruiting perspective
it's very easy for our engineers to
build a brand for themselves
uh which means that we have to be
focused on building the best tech
you know otherwise they have a brand for
themselves right like so we it it
it forces us to build the best uh best
of breed technology
and and build a community around the
best of the technology and
and that's worked well for us understood
thank you
uh abhishek do you guys have any
anything to add
yeah i think uh you said it very nicely
about the open source
uh it's win-win for everybody because
um as us working on open source and the
others other big companies working open
source
uh we collectively then progress you all
watching um agenda and the
aspirations that that project can
actually achieve
which is which might take much longer if
the company is doing it alone so
there's definitely a lot of executions
that come out of open source
from other companies other people
for engineers
it's again
it's pretty beneficial because they get
to
not only build their profile which they
can showcase
in the open market and
they can add to the resume and it acts
to resume value
but also when they are moving around
between the companies since multiple
companies are working on these open
source technologies
they look for people who have a certain
skill set
in these popular open source projects so
uh as individuals as engineers uh we
also get
a competitive advantage and then you get
whenever you join a
new company you are already bootstrapped
with bunch of different
uh technologies in the space which you
can
immediately start to leverage in your
new role and
getting started becomes much more
smoother so it's swimming for everyone
there's
a bit of coordination challenges you
have everyone has to come together and
without organizational boundaries to
make things happen but
it has been patterns through apache and
others have now
been established and works um
but i don't see much downsides and it's
mostly positive understood
i i think um you folks all covered it um
very very very well um have i
watched open source kind of talent that
open source
does attract is there is no bounce to it
and if you're thinking of open source
contributions and things like that
i think one thing to bear in mind is uh
it doesn't matter what your background
is
right i think open source truly lets
your work speak for yourself
and it doesn't really discriminate like
hey are you from this college or this
university or anything like that right
it really empowers you to really bring
yourself to the
project so as long as you have an idea
you want to contribute
most open source projects are you know
they have open arms to sort of take the
contributions in
so i think it's a great equalizer from
that point of view and
uh it i've seen tremendous sorts of
growth
uh in open source projects compared to
the corresponding sort of forks within
companies so i think it's uh
it's it's a great um talent pool so the
perfect meritocracy is i think what i'm
hearing
very good point wonderful thank you
let's continue
[Music]
so i'll double click on goblin which was
something we talked about
um and takes care of primary data
injection
so uh when operating at the scale and
delivering structured and unstructured
data
the challenge starts to get super
complicated
soon enough after you are through say
with couple of
sources or things that you want to deal
with
the more databases the more
file systems you deal with it becomes
more and more challenging
to write custom scripts and or use
traditional systems for etl
to move data across and manage data
across
so linkedin started off with goblin
several years back where they tried to
solve challenge
where um they tried to build a system
where which is generic enough
where it can be extended to support
multiple connectors
and we keep data from multiple places
write data to multiple places and that
was the origination of uh
goblin but as things pressed uh goblin
actually
evolved more and more into data
management space because
um i think we can go to the next slide
uh there's a
cloud of uh word cloud which basically
describes
uh how often goblin shows up for
different kind of data management use
cases
so as uh linkedin evolved the
requirements evolved and linkedin went
from being a startup
um to a big company
the generic nature of goblin allowed
linkedin to evolve it into a system
where
it not only works for engation but
also for different aspects of management
like
data retention format management
because once you have the data in the
ecosystem you want to manage it
differently or keep in different formats
depending on the use case
you might uh to store it in a polymer
format or you might
want to store you know some custom
format uh
depending on the query type and
whatnot so uh and as
things progressed and the compliance
requirements became more and more
stringent and the world evolved
goblin even for the expander to do
things that have to do with compliance
uh and then there are a lot of numerous
use cases like data quality auditing
um replication um that also
uh goblin expanded to cover so
i think this uh we can go to next slide
and i can talk about
uh a few other things
that a skill system needs to provide in
goblin did provide
so i talked about the uh rich
connector integration that problem
evolved into providing and uh given its
um sending interface it continues to add
more and more connectors
to different source and things but also
as you operate at the scale
and you operate with multiple different
systems
um you have this requirement where you
want to support multiple platforms
at different level of the scales which
again goblin evolved to
and supports different kind of
modes where you can run goblin you can
run it as standalone
on a single box and just do basic data
ingestion or data management through
that
or you can run in a cluster mode on bare
metal host or on cloud
or in a cluster of uh standalone
machines uh bare metal machines
um then like i was talking about it
uh that for any system that has to work
at linkedin scale
um and the variety of diversity of the
use cases linkedin has
it has to be extensible so bubbling has
proven to be that system where
it uh covers different aspects of data
management and it's
we are fairly extensible and a lot of
not many capital
capabilities have been added to it all
the time
uh also as you operate at scale and
you're dealing you have that many users
like every different team that has some
kind of data
use case wants to get data manage their
data
uh it becomes very important for them to
um have some sort of salsa so they're
not dependent on
a specific small set of people um
sres or operational people to help them
on board or do any activity so uh
goblin has this uh self-service through
goblin service
uh where people do
uh self-onboarding uh by defining their
data sets and the activities that are
needed with data assets
and of course uh when you you are
running like goblin
uh you need
a fairly robust ability just provides
you with
some ways to control and
measure and uh make the opportunity
uh and um easier so
that's been about goblin um
happy to take questions now later about
it yeah we take one quick question right
goblin
seems like something that works really
well at scale now of course there are
people here
from various types of companies smaller
middle big size companies right
a product that you would recommend for
most people to actually get to know is
this very commonly used in industry or
is it very specific niche in terms of
only big companies really applying
goblin so
uh it has mostly been popular with
big companies but i've seen not many
startups also
our mid-size companies also use it um
the community is actually pretty diverse
and
uh given its different modes in which
goblin can
run uh it's actually fit for everyone
who wants to use it so if if you're a
startup and you have a simple data
injection use case
you want to get started with the
technology which can serve that purpose
and top in that case
you would run on a single machine or you
might want to run it on a couple of
machines
on cloud and uh just on your basic
um data edition use cases but as you
scale if you're using a technology like
goblin
you won't have to redesign the
architecture the system as you grow as a
company
and uh you can start leveraging more and
more features
there's uh integrations uh the our data
management capabilities problem provides
and
run things at the scale on yarn and on
azure or aws so then at that case
um problem like has proven scale you can
also scale up
with goblin so it's actually fit for all
companies all data sizes
um and uh yeah
thank you every shake that's very
helpful and by the way uh i audience
just i know a lot of questions are
coming in
we will have a separate section at the
end where we'll pick some of the
questions and ask the
experts on those questions so uh don't
worry we'll get there
all right let's continue
yeah i mean given that there are lots of
questions maybe we can skip the slide
and go to the next
yeah uh sarita you want to take over
um so i think so far um you've sort of
seen how
uh the data sort of lands you know you
could use tools like goblin
and so on and get data into your data
lakes
so then the next question is hey how do
i compute
all the various analytics uh based off
of this so
um at linkedin we have a wide spread of
uh compute engines that we um actually
use we've
we've had a fairly long legacy of using
um
pig hive and other sort of mapreduce
based
compute engines earlier as well
our current uh sort of trend is to move
all our computer logic to spark where
as was mentioned earlier in the talk
about 80 percent of our compute actually
runs on
spark today and we are looking to
convert pretty much all our compute to
uh to spark going forward uh spark is
great
for batch sort of processing where you
don't really need to interact with the
data
but uh if you want like quick sort of
uh interactive queries that you want to
launch you know like slice and dice that
wasn't was mentioning earlier
uh we also have presto internally for uh
interactive sql query
um we use um tensorflow for
our deep learning use cases and uh first
uh streaming which is the near uh sort
of near line
near uh real-time sort of use cases um
we have um we have samsung
and um uh it it may not be very obvious
but
uh pretty much all of these are open
source technologies that
uh that we build on uh internally and so
is that one question you said that
you're moving to 100
spark in the near future right um what's
the rationale there why would you do
that
right um great question so actually uh
if you look at our evolution we started
off with
um you know just uh scripts running on
um
oracle db snapshots right like if you
think of how we recommend
uh people to uh connect with on linkedin
we sort of started off with those
scripts and those were
they would take a long time to run and
our recommendations would be like
refreshed once every month or six months
when linkedin uh started off uh pig and
uh uh mapreduce technologies
in that sense they actually are they
made these things run so much faster
because now you have distributed compute
at your disposal uh span uh changed that
sort of space even further right so it's
it's a much better technology
uh it provides for in-memory uh
computation
and it's also backed with a very
powerful sql engine
so your computations actually run uh way
faster
spark also has the advantage of allowing
both
sort of imperative like you can write
your own sort of compute logic
as you see fit and as wasn't mentioned
earlier uh ai engineers
really like that aspect of it right like
it's free form you can express your
queries uh your compute logic in the way
that you would like
uh it also has a powerful sql interface
so data
analysts and data scientists actually
love that aspect of
um of spark so that's from sort of a
user
point of view right uh from uh
infrastructure provider point of view if
you're thinking of a company like
linkedin which which has like huge
compute workload
uh spark um changes the equation there
pretty heavily right like it's a very
efficient engine
our resource utilization is is so much
more efficient uh once we move to spark
um the runtime of your patch jobs
actually uh reduces by a lot we have
seen
almost a three x reduction in our jobs
uh runtimes
when we move from pick to spark right so
those are uh efficiencies that just sort
of
uh gather up uh very uh very nicely
uh the trend in the industry is also
more
so i think earlier batch processing was
okay like you could get your data
once a day refresh your dashboards once
a day and that used to be fine
the train now is moving more towards
early sub early
you know minutes sort of latencies right
and i think spark is
really well positioned for that it
naturally sort of brings those
latencies down it's got good support for
streaming and it sort of
continues to improve right so uh those
are i think
aspects that uh that makes park really
um exciting for us here at linkedin
wonderful thank you sunita there's one
question coming from the audience which
i think is very relevant to the
conversation we're having here
uh caution banerjee asks you know are
there deep learning use cases you can
maybe uh share
so obviously deep learning is something
of great interest to uh
i think the community in general uh
maybe one or two use cases of deep
learning at linkedin
sure um so there are uh i think a lot of
our
recommendations at this point are
actually uh going through deep learning
uh one um sort of i guess uh use case is
also
like uh standardization of member uh
skills
and uh titles and and so on
um vasanth abhishek or sumita maybe
folks can add
more more use cases to it
and so essentially uh you know the use
cases are
plenty i think the main the main thing
is that it allows you to
crunch a lot more of data without being
much more
you can be much more agnostic about how
you choose pictures
right so one of the things that we will
notice is that
it will kind of replace some of the
stuff they're already doing because
ai engineers to just throw in the
kitchen stick and hope that the magic
works
and it will also empower lots of other
stuff i'm not at liberty to talk about
some of the stuff that we're doing
uh for unfortunately reasons but you
know from a
practicality perspective it allows you
to do a lot more crunching and a lot
less
human engineering ahead of time right
that's kind of what it works
wonderful so i think saddle we do only
have 15 minutes of which i want at least
five to ten minutes for question answers
so
let's continue thank you
um so uh i'll i'll try to wrap this up
fairly quick but so if you're
uh if you've seen our trend so far we've
sort of said like hey we use open source
technologies a lot and especially apache
spark is something that's
fully built by the community right and
you might be wondering hey
what does linkedin have to do then once
you know like we bring spark in
what what does the team really do within
linkedin and uh so this slide sort of
tries to uh
shed some light on that right so while
apache spark
open source version actually does work
really well
uh at linkedin scale we have our own set
of problems to solve so
at the bottom of this uh pyramid you see
that there is a resource management
aspect of it right
so as over time i think the number of
use cases that
we've sort of started seeing running on
our offline ecosystem it's
it's grown and as linkedin has grown the
amount of data that we deal with
you know it just grows exponentially
right so there's a continuous demand
for uh better resource management both
in terms of efficiency and just
availability
and the second layer you actually have
um
challenges with the compute engine which
is
uh as your data really grows that much
how do you now crunch
more data in pretty much the same sort
of time limits right so that's
uh the second uh layer of the funnel and
uh
on top of that we have user productivity
sort of issues
so while apache spark is really great in
terms of you know providing a lot of
value it has a lot of knobs that folks
have to be very
proficient with in terms of tuning so
they can get their jobs running so
that leads to a lot of user productivity
related um
use cases for us to solve uh next slide
sort of talks about
uh some of the solutions that have been
able to
bring to this um so for the resource
management aspects we've actually
worked on the yarn level yarn is another
open source
scheduling layer that linkedin depends
on and we have
self-service queues here that allow our
users to actually say
how much resources they need for their
teams or their organizations and it
allows
it to sort of grow or shrink elastically
we're also moving to cloud we're moving
to azure so we can
leverage the native sort of elastic sort
of
limits of azure as well
in terms of compute engine optimizations
uh we've seen a lot of bottlenecks here
at linkedin at our scale so
we're working on improving uh some of
the very underlying sort of primitives
that apache spark works on which is
called shuffle
and we've also done quite a few
optimizations at the sequel layer itself
that's the compute optimizations part of
it
in terms of user productivity we've
invested a lot in terms of
tooling and automation so in the next
slide
we can see one of our open source uh
projects which is around uh helping
users understand
um their job performance offline job
performance right so we call this
dr elephant and basically this sort of
once your job runs it looks at your job
and it says okay
this is where your common problems are
you've not tuned this parameter
hey you've allocated either too much
memory here or too little
so on and so forth and it provides
heuristic sort of based
actions and recommendations for users to
uh
to take charge of and it also gives you
a nice sort of performance comparison
over time saying how
how has your job sort of trended over
time right so these are sort of the
additional things that
we do here at linkedin on top of the
existing sort of open source uh
technologies uh dr elephant also has a
huge
uh and growing community in terms of
adoption uh
across uh uh uh the company sorry
uh across the industry and here are some
of the uh key players in that space
a lot of big names we recognize a lot of
them from india as well you see flipkart
over there
wonderful this is a global business
makes total sense wonderful all right
i think we are going to the most
interesting question here and the reason
i have not asked these questions from
the audience to you yet because we were
going to cover it anyway
i think there are a lot of questions
about careers in big data look the four
or few have done really well in this
industry and so i think a lot of people
who are pretty new to this i think they
would love to hear more about
how do i start my career in big data so
over to you you know
abhishek love to hear more about this
slightly different things if you are at
the starting out
you know phase of your career where your
student or fresh college record
it's never uh it's never been easier to
be protest
right a lot of this is very popular uh
let's
like sunita alluded to earlier um
it's a pretty uh cryptocurrency
enterprise um there's some
noise i hope it's not from me but i i
think obviously we might have to go on
mute i think there's a little
there you go okay perfect so there's a
you know it's a pretty
meritocratic enterprise i would
encourage you guys um and you folks uh
to all look at some of these open source
technologies
um start engaging with the community you
know maybe write a connector write
something on the edges
and you know you'll get a pulse for
whether this is a good career for you or
not
at a fairly low investment cost for you
right it it it's a
it can lit stuff as a hobby actually
start off
from there and we've had very good
success hiring people from
with who have shown passion um you know
one of my one of
the tech leads or one of our big
products was basically someone who
worked on an open source
thing as a side hobby and then he got
interested in what linkedin was doing
he's now started his own company right
so there's there's lots of
real track records of people starting
off this way if you are sort of in the
middle of your career and you're
interested in what's going on it's it's
relatively easy to transition from
related spaces right it's if you're an
oracle database person or if you're
working in
you know teradata or something like that
it's very easy to transition into the
infrastructure side of the stack um but
as i said it's a vast stack
right and it and you know if you're a
statistician it's fairly easy to become
a data scientist
you might have to learn some pattern you
might have to learn some r um
and so on and so forth so understand
what your related spaces are
understand whether the domain excites
you right it's
uh and it's fairly easy to make these
transitions if you kind of
understand where in the stack you can
add the most value and
you know the retooling is not terribly
complicated
um do you all want to add anything
and i do have some specific questions
once uh your answer
i agree with wasn't right having an
interest in the big data space and then
uh
you know getting familiar with sequels
and
um whatever like uh having some
experience in the scripting background
should be good enough to get started in
the space
and then yeah you you would be learning
i mean it's a learning journey for
everybody even now
so yeah i think you should you shouldn't
getting scared you know uh you need to
be like an excellent programmer or
anything to get started like all you
need is like
one knowledge of sql engine and then
some scripting language i think you're
good to go like you can start you know
building some pipelines everything is
open source right now there are multiple
courses available online so
it's just you know you need to get
started and
yeah you will be uh building your skills
along the way
so so maybe a question for you and the
rest of the panel it came in from the
audience from youtube by the way
so the question really is at an entry
level what does linkedin actually expect
because it's
it's one thing to say if you do sql and
scripting you're good to start but
if you look at the entry criteria for
linkedin for an entry level role what
would that be
what are the kind of things you look for
that might be very interesting for those
folks here to understand
so uh for for generally for data
engineering background
like experience working in one sql
language uh
experience in one scripting language
like python or something
um that's like the basic minimum
qualifications to even
you know apply for the job and uh rest
is in the interviews right like
just preparing yourself for the
interviews and
cracking it so i think the
to be honest like these two couple of
skills should be good enough to start
yourself as a data engineer
this is if you want to work on the
platform side um you may need
experience you know working in one of
the object oriented languages
and then so that should make yourself
you know
competitive in the job market if you
want to work on the platform side
um yeah pretty much that's it wonderful
so nithya shake any other additional
thoughts i'm sure you started somewhere
as well so any insights
i think uh primarily
uh if you're looking at more paken and
uh
more of infrasight than um
python helps uh if you're focusing more
on data science side then
potentially uh some interest in
mathematical domain and
uh statistics would definitely um there
isn't
much requirement of um
deep experience with open source tech uh
remember
that uh big data is a very used
it ranges from um adding the infra
using the infra for different use cases
data
science uh ai um so
there's not many things you can do and
you can get started in this uh domain
uh even for mid career professionals uh
even if you have
exposure to sql because there are a lot
of sql uh engines out there
in the big data space and uh you can
bring your
experience from the other domain and uh
very easily translate it here you
definitely need not a passion
um try to take on things because
it is definitely a big space
i i just wanted to add one thing um i
think computer science
computer engineering degrees definitely
give you an edge but
uh linkedin also has a program that's
called
reach r-e-a-c-h so if you are from
non-traditional backgrounds and you do
want to sort of
um you know get started with these
things do check that program out it's
sort of like an internship i don't know
but
may probably know uh if this is run in
bangalore but you know just just as an
option um for folks to consider
uh wonderful then at the expense go
ahead please i don't know if it's done
in bangalore but reach is
a really good call out it's it's in many
ways we've hired people who are
biochemists who are interested in this
space they're bright people they've had
some of them even at phds but they're
from a different domain
and it gives people an extended
opportunity to
work in an embedded setting cover the
delta gaps that they have and transition
into a career
and um you know linkedin kind of
pioneered some of the stuff but it's not
unique to linkedin by any stretch
so at the cost of potentially
embarrassing myself i'm going to ask a
question here as well that comes from
the audience which i think is very
relevant
so you know you have these boot camps
data science and you know simply learn
ourselves right
it looks at when you say get started do
these boot camp kind of experiences
add any credibility or value to what you
consider a serious candidate
i i think we look for experiences and
you know clearly it's a sign of an
experience right
um i i think you know with any candidate
you kind of look for a few different
things right you look for ownership
passion experience
and raw level knowledge that comes
through the interviews
and all of these are signals right um
and and that's a useful signal
wonderful these kind of uh programs
definitely
give you a jump start um and uh
in this noisy space with so many
different technologies
um these programs give you a very
structured introduction
and a very solid introduction where
um they typically end up with some kind
of
practical exposure with some sort of
projects but then there's no substitute
for your own self-drive and passion so
you definitely need to be passionate
about
getting to the space um and these are
definitely good launchers
what about the philanthropy all right so
we're going to wind up
here with a pole to the question um now
that you've heard the conversation
you want to have a simple poll right in
terms of your interest in transitioning
into the big data
space in career right how soon or how
important how quickly are you going to
transition
so please answer honestly we'd love to
see you know what the level of interest
here is
instead i'll let you do the push
all right i don't hear stuart but we'll
give it another 10 15 seconds this
should be an easy easy question
second countdown for now all right there
you go
so please remember to hit enter submit
and we'll close the poll in 10 seconds
5 4 3 two
one and
i see a lot of immediate interest
wonderful so i think you know what's
exciting is i think we've had
a you know very good turnout and it's
very clear there's a lot of interest in
the space so
this is a great place to thank sumita
sunita vasanth and abhishek
folks thank you so much for making the
time giving us a glimpse of the life you
lead at lincoln
linkedin today and the kind of change
you're bringing within the company and
providing some of that wisdom to the
team here
um hugely appreciate this thank you
thank you very much
my pleasure very much
wonderful stuart back to you
i unmute myself and i do want to thank
anand for hosting and moderating the
event
and thank you again to our panel thank
you to everybody here
who came and we'd like to
invite you to our next webinar
which will be uh next tuesday
same time uh this one in the subject of
uh ai
in fintech and we have a special guest
the ceo and co-founder of zest money
lizzie chapman
so we hope to see a lot of you there
if you have friends who are interested
in ai or fintech or both
please let them know and
please connect with us on simplylearn at
facebook twitter linkedin um
connect with us directly so we look
forward to having you in future webinars
and
look forward to having you join the
simply learn community
thank you so much and this concludes our
webinar
stuart thank you adam thank you
you